hey guys our new merch designs are
finally
here so the only problem is we couldn't
choose on just one so we chose two this
is my favorite habac 3 and this is the
design Nikita loves y you like yours
more than mine well I like I like both
that's why we took both of them yeah
that's true this is just a reminder for
you guys to always remember that you can
never find true peace and joy in this
world from temporary materialistic
things it comes only from God himself
even when you go through trials and
tribulations you only find it in God and
so he will make your feet like that of a
deer To Tread on high places there we go
love you guys get the merch get it for
someone out there who you need who you
know might need it love you bye bye